i've been hard on dwight because  as i was criticizing him i was also  giving him answers to the tests  see  i like criticism because  remember i told you i could stop time  when you criticize i will stop time and  see if there's any truth in that  criticism  shaq's a great player but he won't do  anything until he hit the free throws  you're right  can't be mad at that instead of going  shut up i'm averaging 20 points  so i'm able to stop time and see if  there's any truth in the criticism wow i  would criticize him all the time but  also say if he averages 28 15  and bring that up to 30 in the playoffs  he's going to win he's going to dominate  kept saying the whole time but he  thought i was hating so i mean i don't i  don't know the difference but  when i criticize i try to give these  guys vital information and they don't  even know it because they can't get past  the criticism